hey guys we're going to be doing a live  show at politican this October here in  LA what's politican no it's not a  transformer that digs politics it's a  great new event where people from both  sides of the aisle come together to talk  politics entertainment and everything in  between I'm going to be on a panel  hosted by David Webb from Fox News  alongside Ann Coulter as well as a panel  hosted by Sirius XM's Rick Ungar oh and  i'll be hosting a live reuben report  with guest michael steele former  chairman of the Republican National  Committee check out or a dot TV / Ruben  report to find out how to win free  tickets and come see us do a live show  you  you